joe biden's record being called into
question once again after going back and
forth on how progressive he really is
here's what joe is now saying about
fracking after being attacked
by president trump i am
not banning frackie let me say that
again
i am not banning frackie no matter how
many times
donald trump lies about me
but it wasn't that long ago when biden
was saying this
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal and fracking
in the biden administration no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated and no more
subsidies
for either one of those i'm talking
about stopping fracking
as soon as we possibly can no ifs
butts and maybes about it i'm talking
about something
to try well i'm not sure your proposal
does that and i would not stop fracking
i'd gradually move away from frackie i
would just not
do more fracking on federal lands
so i'll go to you first juan uh which
joe biden there's
telling the truth i mean they
fact-checked president trump for
everything
which one well you know
dan i think politicians often say one
thing to
an audience in the primaries and say
something a little different in the
general so
in the primaries i think he was catching
up to
bernie sanders and saying hey you know
what we're not going to have
fracking uh with an emphasis there on
private lands right no fracking on
private lands but then he now i'm yeah
i'm getting confused here but
in the primaries he said no fracking on
private on on
on no frat king in general but what he
was talking about was
on public lands and now he's emphasizing
that he would in fact a lot not have
fracking on government land but allow it
on private land so
he emphasizes one thing in the primaries
and another thing in the general
the distinction being between public and
private lands but i mean
you see this on the other side trump's
not exactly saying
you know what we've got covent under
control or i'm going to fix health care
in a couple days
that stuff's all gone that was an
interesting deflection
why is it always about trump every time
i mean it was a simple segment here
right
greg uh one of the i didn't actually is
making my point
but president trump in the primary said
a lot of things and pretty much stuck to
it
biden seems to be flip-flopping on just
about everything right now
including his comment about redirecting
funding away from the police where he
said absolutely
you've just hit the distinction trump is
not a politician
biden is joe is treating the
democratic left like a one-night stand
you know he made all these promises to
get them in the sack
now it's see you later bernie and here's
some cab fare
but when you lead a life in which all
you're trying to do is get
political power you become joe's
essentially a weather vein
with hair plugs and unfortunately the
wind is blowing from the left
mostly from bernie and aoc but he's
painted himself in a corner
he got prague support by veering left
but he needs american votes so he's got
to get back to the middle
so but if he gets back to the middle
then he starts sounding like trump and
then the left
his left wing allies will burn will bury
him alive
or dead not sure which so dana you've
done communications at the highest level
i mean the problem i think liberals have
now i mean any politicians you say
but any politician specifically biden
when they lie is it's on tape and you
know if walter cronkite didn't mention
it 30 years ago it didn't happen
now you can just go to youtube and watch
joe biden say no no i'm going to ban
fracking and then say he's not going to
ban fracking kind of an issue no
yeah technology has been a great
leveling
for conservatives and republicans when
it comes to the media
i do think that there's another example
that you could see where the media
helped paper over
something that joe biden said in which
he said elect me
and your taxes are going to go up pretty
incredible moment right
but what happened was when the trump
campaign put that in an ad
uh politifact came out and said no no no
no he didn't mean that
he didn't mean that well that's not
really
fact checking that's just basically
papering over something that would be
unpopular in a general election campaign
emily your thoughts right this is just
like hillary's comment in 2016 where she
said we're going to put a lot of coal
miners out of business
both nominees said it both wished they
hadn't and both campaigns spent a lot of
time trying to clean it up but here
biden is trying to blame trump for lying
over it
but that just creates more fodder that
can prove him wrong
all that needs to play is one commercial
of a montage like we just did
with all of his fracking answers in
pennsylvania and he'll be down in flames